kelly justin congratulations you've made
it to the final round which means you're
both one step closer to the title of
forged and fire champion and receiving
that check for 10 grand now we're
sending you back to your home forges
where we're asking you to forge an
iconic weapon from history
the falcata
the falcata is a curved chopping weapon
with a sharpened point it was popular in
pre-roman iberia in what is now spain
and portugal it is unknown whether the
weapon was created in iberia or evolved
from designs in central europe and
greece
whatever its origins it earned its
reputation as a killer
employed by spanish infantry the falcada
allowed its user to deliver a blow with
the force of an axe while cutting like a
sword hannibal of carthage was so
impressed by this spanish blade that he
equipped many of his african troops with
it those armed with a falcata would rely
on speed and agility against the heavily
armored roman soldiers
bladesmiths you will have five days to
accomplish this at the end of those five
days you will return and present your
finished falcatas to our panel of expert
judges who will then submit them to a
serious very rigorous tests
good luck bladesmiths we'll see you in
five days
[Music]
here we are at my home forge where i'm
very comfy i love it here i have an
awesome set of tools i know what glue is
what
i'm ready to roll
i'm real comfortable building a falcata
i like that shape of blade probably the
most challenging part are going to be to
decorate it to where it really pops out
i've decided since i am a farrier that i
should probably go for the decorative
horse head on the end of the handle
i'm taking a fair amount of time to try
to get the look of this horse down
because you know i want the perfect
horse and i want the horse that goes
with that knife
very important to know your horse
anatomy
he looks like he's about to take a big
hunk out of you
it's going to be a lot of work but i
want to hand in the coolest project and
i want something that's true to the era
but it's got a little kelly in it too
i'm excited to be back home with tools
i'm familiar with but i have a big
challenge ahead of me and some really
tough competition
today i'd like to design the blade and
start forging
i'm not a swordsmith i'm a bladesmith
the falcaoda is a large sword but a big
part of bladesmithing is problem-solving
so i'm going to be using a leaf spring
it's very thick it's very heavy
it's the end of day one what i have is a
pointy metal stick
tomorrow's gonna be a long day
day three i'm feeling really good about
the progress
you can find to me the heat treat it
went really well everything's nice and
straight so
just chugging right along
i'm just gonna tighten up the handle a
little bit cause historically it kind of
wraps around and protects your hand
i cut out a v and it's mild steel right
there so i'm just gonna take a little
hand torch and heat this up a little bit
and just bend around re-weld it
so i like the shape of it better now it
welded up nice you can't really see a
seam i like it
it's my last day i need to get a finish
on this blade glue up the handles and
then sharpen them
making a blade this big with just the
tools i have at my disposal is a lot of
work
but i think i did as good a job as
anybody could do and i feel this is a
winning weapon
i think kelly should be worried she's
gonna have to bring a blade that can
perform just as well
or better cool and that's quite a
challenge for anybody i believe
bladesmiths to see how sharp your blades
are i will take your weapon and i will
see how well it does against these fish
kelly you're up first are you ready yep
going into the testing i'm just glad
when it's over and i'll be back to
normal kelly not stressed out kelly
because i'm much more fun when i'm
normal kelly
[Music]
well kelly your blade definitely is
designed to chop through it cut to the
first two fish and almost on the third
one
this
will cut
good job
justin you're up next are you ready i'm
ready let's do this
watching kelly's blade go through two
and a half fish set the bar high and i
have no idea how this thing will perform
[Music]
well justin your bleed is sharp it cut
all the way through the first and second
and into the third
it'll cut
next stop is a strength test
smith's on the battlefield the falcata
didn't only hit skin it had other swords
armor and shields so to test the
strength of your blade we're going to
use our device here
to take three blows into the steel edge
of this shield
if your blades are made properly that
edge should hold up
if not we'll see what happens
kelly you're up first you ready
sure okay
i'm a little nervous about the strength
test
don't be a soft piece of garbage just be
good
in
three
two
one
[Music]
three
two
one
i thought i was seeing a crack
but it's just discoloration
the edge held up beautifully it's still
sharp
all in all held up beautifully in this
strength test
justin you ready i'm ready all right
i feel like this final test is really
gonna show what my blade is made of
either it's gonna hold together it's
gonna perform well or it may break in
half i have no idea three
two
one
[Music]
all right last time three
two one
well i'm impressed
no deformation it's still sharp nicely
done
but
that's scary
very scary
it's in a position that if blade rotates
one direction it's going to go right
into the pad of the thumb rotates the
other direction it's going to cut into
the tendons in the back of the hand
that's an issue but
all in all it did well in the machine
good job thank you
kelly justin
before i announce the forged fire
champion the judges have something
they'd like to say to both of you
jason
kelly one of the things i appreciate the
most is how you forged the horse head i
like the way it looked also it's
traditional for a falcata to have a
horse head overall it was a beautiful
piece thank you very nice
dave
justin you came up with a design there
that is a complete intimidator
i mean you look at that thing and you
know it's going to hurt you if it gets
close to you i really appreciate you
bringing something that is solidly yours
means a lot thank you
kelly justin
you've both done very impressive work
however on this day
there can only be one forest and fire
champion
kelly congratulations you were the
forged and fire champion
justin unfortunately your blade did not
make the cut justin the handle is a
connection between the end user and the
blade your handle construction with that
hook being sharp could potentially hurt
the person wielding it which
unfortunately prevents it from being a
fully functional weapon and it's for
that reason that your blade did not make
the cut justin please surrender your
weapon
it was close it's nice to know that with
five days of hard work i can impress
judges that have seen many swords and
competed with some of the best
bladesmiths in the country to do that is
really rewarding
kelly congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion you will also be
receiving a check for 10 000 how does
that make you feel feels great
i think that thing's great it's straight
up right out of the history books i mean
it's got all the elements which is
really neat including the horse head
it's awesome you're our first female
champion no it just still doesn't seem
quite real it feels great to be the
fortune fire champion the first farrier
forage and fire champion i'm the first
chick for some fire champion that's
pretty cool i pulled it off
you